foreign
[Music]
it's the weekend and here is the latest
important news about movies and series
find out what's next for John Wick what
Quentin Tarantino's final movie will be
about and who won the Academy Awards
this year there are also exciting new
images for Transformers rise of the
beasts and Spider-Man across the
spider-verse along with an announcement
about the next Scream movie so stay
tuned
just about everyone knows at least one
of Quentin Tarantino's Nine Movies
whether it's Pulp Fiction Kill Bill and
glorious bastards or Django Unchained
there's something for any genre fan even
though the films differ greatly in terms
of plot they are all categorized by the
typical Tarantino style explicit
violence long and absurd dialogues and
plenty of Easter eggs on other films in
addition you often see the same actors
such as Samuel L Jackson Brad Pitt or
Christophe Waltz now there is some first
information available regarding
Tarantino's last film ever the director
made it clear very early in his career
that he had set himself the magic number
of 10 films and would definitely quit
after that that's why people were all
the more Curious until the very end as
to which film The 59 year old would make
there was speculation some time ago for
example about a sequel to Kill Bill but
that seems to be a thing of the past now
according to the Hollywood Reporter
Tarantino's new movie is titled the
movie critic it is set in 1970s Los
Angeles much like once upon a time in
Hollywood the script for this film
finale has already been penned and there
is also a solid theory about the plot
according to the report the focus will
be on author Pauline kale who at the
time made a name for herself not only as
a film critic but also as an essayist
and writer it's no secret that Tarantino
is a big fan of kale who passed away in
2001 the 1970s also fit perfectly as the
period of the film critic's life since
she caused quite a sensation there we
are looking forward to more information
about the movie critic sadly a release
date is not known at the moment
a few days ago a tweet from a Hollywood
Insider about Spider-Man across the
spider-verse began circulating on social
media the reliable informant big screen
leaks commented on whether the second
spider-verse movie will be better than
its predecessor the response was a clear
yes which further increased the
excitement among fans for the sequel due
for release in the summer in addition to
this pleasant but not very significant
information some exclusive images were
released this week via Empire magazine
the first image shows the colorful
mumbatin Universe protected by the
Indian Spider-Man poppeteer prabhakar
moreover on a cover we can see the
skyline of mubaton which will play an
important role in the upcoming film
another image shows the popular
Spider-Man 2099 in battle with the
villain vulture the antagonist is best
known for his appearance in Spider-Man
Homecoming in which he was embodied by
Michael Keaton and had to face Tom
Holland Spider-Man a while later Empire
followed up with an image of main
character Miles Morales and his
girlfriend Gwen Stacy AKA spider Gwen
the two can be seen hanging out on a
house facade the idea is to tie in with
the events of the first part and at the
same time set the stage for the
subsequent film Spider-Man beyond the
spiderverse together miles and other
Spider-Man companions will travel
through several universes to protect the
Earth from a new Mighty villain in order
to achieve this the team plans to go the
extra mile visually by using six
different animation Styles in the film
however the focus is not only on the
visuals Spider-Man across the
spider-verse is also intended to address
the fans emotionally as screenwriter and
producer Christopher Miller recently
revealed in an interview we are
definitely excited and can't wait for
the movie to be released on June 2nd
2023.
the so-called sxsw conference is
currently taking place the focus is also
on movies and series which traditionally
make up a large part of the panels along
with musical performances the event will
last until this Sunday and there are
already some insights that will please
fans of the Transformers franchise in
particular many important actors of the
upcoming Transformers rise of the beasts
showed up including the two main actors
Anthony Ramos and Dominique Fishback as
well as director Stephen cable Jr
besides the star's appearances the
release of three character posters was
the highlight of the panel featured are
Optimus Prime Optimus primal and Mirage
the first two are likely known to many
and are voiced by Peter Cullen and Ron
Perlman Mirage however may not be a
familiar name to everyone the k
character will be dubbed by Pete
Davidson in the upcoming film and is a
silver and blue Porsche 964 Carrera RS
3.8 along with the character posters and
a photo of the aforementioned Porsche
two giant Optimus Prime and Optimus
primal figures from Transformer 7 rise
of the beasts were also shown and were
true fan favorites in terms of Story the
movie is set in 1994 Brooklyn Soldier
Noah and archaeologist Elena get caught
up in an old conflict between the
eponymous machine creatures the various
factions of Predacons terracons and
Decepticons are up against the popular
Optimus Prime and the maximals which
also include the ape-like Optimus primal
it remains unanswered whether the
upcoming Blockbuster will be able to
match the success of Bumblebee or
whether fans will react with
disappointment as was the case with many
previous movies so far however the
majority are still upbeat even after
watching the trailer either way we are
eager to find out how the movie will
perform upon its theatrical release on
June 9th and 23.
with John Wick chapter 4 the next part
of the popular action franchise with
Keanu Reeves is about to be released and
critics are already getting excited
recently director Chad stilleski
commented on why John Wick 5 is
unfortunately not on his mind for the
time being the 54 year old already has
plenty of experience as a stuck
coordinator and was the stunt double for
Keanu Reeves in The Matrix with his
passion project John Wick he then
started one of the most popular
franchises at present as director
together with the called actor in the
past staleski revealed that he could
well imagine five or six parts in total
Keanu Reeves also said he would love to
play the character for as long as he was
physically able to in fact it was even
planned that filming for John Wick
chapter 5 would begin right after the
conclusion of John Wick 4. unfortunately
this is not going to happen for the time
being stoleski explained that he needs a
break after the latest film and doesn't
want to think about a fifth part at the
moment at least not with him as a
director he did not reveal how long this
break would
fans surely wish for a sequel as soon as
possible but should that really happen
at the expense of a director who has
been successful thus far meanwhile there
is also good news Keanu Reeves also
confirmed that he will also appear in
the spin-off ballerina with Anna diarmus
however the story revolves primarily
around hitwoman Rooney Brown and her
revenge on her family's murderers
besides well-known characters like
Winston and Sharon The Walking Dead star
Norman Reedus and Gabriel Byrne have
already been confirmed as cast members
even apart from part 5 we can expect new
additions to the John Wick Universe
ballerina is expected at around the turn
of the year and the spin-off series the
Continental with Mel Gibson will be
available on Amazon Prime video sometime
in 2023. for now fans of the main film
series can look forward to the
theatrical release of John Wick chapter
4 on March 24 2023
Scream 6 is currently running in
theaters and was the most successful
release ever for Wes Craven's famous
horror franchise the movie grossed an
impressive 44 million US Dollars on its
opening weekend after the success of
Scream 5 in 2022 led to a prop sequel
history is now repeating itself as the
website screen geek revealed Scream 7 is
already being worked on at full speed
many were amazed when the new Scream
movie starring Wednesday star Jenna
Ortega hit theaters just one year after
part 5 but horrorflix are known for
being profitable even with moderate box
office takings since they can be
produced comparatively fast and at low
cost Scream 6 is no exception the budget
of 35 million dollars has already been
recouped after the opening weekend
shooting for Scream 7 is therefore
scheduled to begin as early as 2023 so
we expect that theatrical release next
year should the success continue we
might actually be able to look forward
to a new screen film every year in the
future have you watched Scream 6 in
theaters yet and what do you think about
the fast output of new Ghostface movies
feel free to share your thoughts in the
comments
on March 12th the 95th awards ceremony
of the world famous Oscars was held in
Los Angeles the big winner of the
evening with seven Awards is the
surprise hit everything everywhere all
at once which also won the award for
best picture besides Jamie Lee Curtis as
best supporting actress action Legend
Michelle yeoh was the first Asian to win
the award for best actress in a leading
role many were especially happy for best
supporting actor kihi Kwan who after
enjoying success in Indiana Jones and
the Temple of Doom or The Goonies had
not been seen as an actor for many years
due to insufficient offers the war movie
All Quiet on the Western Front won a
total of four Oscars including best
International Film never before has a
German movie been so successful at this
event it is actually also the second
most awarded film of the evening the
whale follows with two Awards include
fan favorite Brendan Fraser as best
leading actor black panther 2 wakanda
forever Avatar 2 the way of water Top
Gun 2 Maverick Guillermo del Toros
Pinocchio and the Indian action film rrr
each won an Oscar despite several
nominations favorites such as the
Banshees of nisharin Elvis the fablemans
and tar came away empty-handed
which piece of news has impressed you
the most this week and are there any
other exciting news that didn't make it
into our video let us know in the
comments besides that we suggest you
check out our clip and trailer
compilation for John Wick chapter 4 so
that you can get even more hyped for the
upcoming movie as always thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]
oh